[Music]
intrauterine insemination also known as
artificial insemination is a procedure
done to help a woman get pregnant
a woman's reproductive system includes
the vagina
cervix
uterus
fallopian tubes
and ovaries
during the monthly menstrual cycle one
of her ovaries releases an egg in a
process called ovulation
after ovulation the egg enters the
fallopian tube
a woman is most likely to become
pregnant if she has sex in the days just
before during or right after ovulation
during this time a sperm cell from a
man's reproductive fluid called semen is
able to fertilize her egg as it moves
through the fallopian tube
intrauterine insemination may be
performed if a woman is having trouble
getting pregnant a condition known as
infertility or it may be done if a woman
wants to have a child without a male
partner
before intrauterine insemination a woman
may receive fertility medication that
causes her to release more than one egg
during ovulation
in a process called sperm washing a
man's sperm will be separated from the
fluid in his semen this concentrates the
sperm removes debris and removes
hormones that may cause the uterus to
cramp if the male partner is completely
infertile also known as sterile or if
the woman does not have a male partner
previously washed and frozen donor sperm
will be used for the procedure
the doctor will monitor the ovaries for
ovulation intrauterine insemination must
be performed right before or right after
a woman ovulates so that an egg is
available for fertilization
during the procedure the woman will lie
on an examination table
a tool called a speculum will be
inserted into her vagina so that the
doctor can see her cervix
a syringe will be loaded with a small
amount of fluid containing the washed
sperm then the syringe will be attached
to a long thin tube called a catheter
the doctor will insert the catheter into
the vagina the tip of the catheter will
be guided through the opening in the
cervix and into the uterus once the
catheter is inside the uterus the doctor
will inject the sperm
then the catheter and speculum will be
removed
the woman may continue to lie on her
back for about ten minutes